malory was this the first time you'd
worked with puppets I know with Yama
song there's they're all animated well
they're not animated they're all there
live-action puppets it is actually not
the first time we've worked with puppets
are the last feature that we did kids
versus monsters some of our monsters
were puppets and we had so much fun with
them and we've just absolutely endured
getting into the world of puppet
filmmaking Wow okay so it's so animation
be where you're you're drawing it or
there's a cartoonist so with this it's
it's like these live-action things that
you're having taught most like a
marionette yes well what it's called
American tabletop and it's an American
version of a Japanese form of puppetry
called Bunraku and instead of and in
Japan it would be all black puppeteers
in like a complete black suit on a black
background doing the puppets and they're
called rod puppets they're about this
big and they have rods stuck into their
joints
sometimes there's mouth and hand
movements but it's mostly rod puppetry
but the way that we do it
is that we have all the puppets on a
green-screen with people in complete
green suits and we digitally remove the
puppeteers and put digital backgrounds
or real backgrounds in behind the
puppets Wow okay so let's take a
10-minute scene with the puppets how
long would that actually take to film it
could take all day it could take a
couple of days there's I mean it's just
like an I mean we're shooting it
live-action so it's sort of like working
just on a regular film set you have to
set everything up you have to light
everything you have to do it several
different times and what the way that we
do it is that we record the voices first
of all the actors and then the
puppeteers actually puppeteer to the
voices and they do it a little bit we
speed the voices up just a little bit so
it ends up looking natural Wow okay so
the script the the the audio is pretty
much already done aside from any type of
music or quality work we we we do our
best and we at least with Yama song we
were able to record all the voices for
all our voice talent first that way our
puppeteers can actually puppeteer
perfectly to the you know up to all the
different inflections and the voices so
then I would imagine that the script is
locked at that point in terms of
dialogue and everything
definitely
okay I mean we can I mean we can change
the scenes around a little bit but
dialogue wise we're locked in you're
locked in okay and so then the puppeteer
is what's their process for listening to
the dialogue so they really get a feel I
mean we play it in the onset we have it
blasting out of speakers so they they're
hearing it they're they've read the
script they're familiar what's going on
and they're listening over and over
again to to the lines so they I mean by
the end of it they they know everything
perfectly once you get on set how much
time do the puppeteers have actually
getting a feel for the different animal
that they're working with because they
were all animals in the there they're
sort of humanoid animals but they're
they'll they'll take they'll take time
to you know get a feel for the puppet
how it moves they'll do a bunch of test
scenes you know just see how it's going
to work because fitting when a puppet to
this big some of I mean some of our
puppets take five people to puppeteer so
it's it's a very interesting
choreographed movement to get all five
people because one person might be just
doing one to arms and one person would
be doing two legs one person with me
doing the head so there's definitely
some test runs before we start shooting
just to get it all moving correctly when
you were little did you go to puppet
shows I actually had my own marionette
theater that my grandfather built me
I've always really loved puppets and I
would put on little shows with the
marionettes so it's always there's
something about puppet filmmaking and
being able to have total control and
being able to move these these either
humanoids or animals and I mean this
obviously the more things that you can
do with puppets than you can do with
real humans and there's an exaggeration
and a hyperbole of emotion and movement
that you get from puppets that is
physically impossible from humans and
it's it's similar to animation in the
way that you can get these big big
movements and these big these big
emotions and these big ideas with
puppets that and it's just so fun and so
rewarding and it's a very interesting
way of telling a story so with each of
the puppeteers let's suppose there's
going to be two puppeteers working on
one puppet how much backstory do they go
into for that
one character - no kind of even its body
language and let's suppose it's a more
demure the animal figure versus a more
extroverted one well I think the PI mean
the puppeteers are there just like
actors and they have they all have their
own method of getting into the character
and understanding the character and
after they've read the script I mean
ever everyone's different but they
definitely sort of have an idea of who
the character is what their motivations
are what they love what they want in
this scene it's just it's like being
dealing with a teeny tiny little actor
you